ever been sick and symptom searched in
Google no fear that's the problem that
giant will help solving giant questions
she has a doctor and takes it to the
most correct possibilities and tells you
what to do rather to stay at home or go
to the doctor here's how it works the
giant database is powered by a trusted
team of doctors around the world imagine
a world where everyone has a doctor in
their pocket regardless of whether they
are rich or poor the best thing about it
is it's free for everyone you can access
giant easily through facebook Messenger
just click on new message and write
giant that's it no application no
download if you're interested click on
the link in description preview for the
fifth episode just dropped and it
contains some very interesting shots so
without further due let's just jump into
it it starts with the nearest promising
to either Endel or his santak entirely
that she will spare their life if they
bend the knee in my opinion the head of
house Tarly Randall is going to be burnt
alive by Danish dragon as a result of
his betrayal over his stone house Tyrell
and most importantly for pledging his
forces to search his cause
Randall's son Deacon on the other hand
will as you can hear in this preview get
a chance to either bend the knee or
swear fealty to her or to refuse and die
this outcome is not surprising at all
since the nurse said herself child
should not be judged by the sins of
their father then we get to see outcome
of a huge battle that happened in the
last episode which is basically
everything being burned down in the next
shot versus being concerned about
Daenerys and says to Tyrion that he
needs to find a way to make her listen
worse might being concerned about the
nearest burning the head of house Tarly
alive but he might be concerned about
something entirely else as well
Daenerys might decide to attacking
Landing with her dragons and Varys would
definitely be concerned about that as
not only that the thousands of innocent
people would die but the nurses life
would be in danger as well then we get
to see a shot of Dragon with Daenerys on
his back landing near Jon Snow you don't
have to worry for Jon since he's the
blood of the Dragon himself and
therefore he will not get eaten alive
but will rather feed or pet dragon which
I'm sure will be very shocking and
surprising for Daenerys then we get a
shot from the red keep Cersei says to
Qyburn whoever stands in our way we will
defeat it next shot contains Winterfell
and flock of Ravens being sent out and a
bit later we find those Ravens so which
one is being war
by brand beyond the wall upon seeing the
night king and his army marching towards
eastwatch-by-the-sea bran will send a
raven to Jon Snow
beside revealing him where the night
king currently is and where he's heading
to bran will also inform Jon that he and
Arya finally arrived home and have
finally reunited with each other
I'm sure John's reaction will be
priceless